bonsoir alors président devenir
président bonsoir là
[Rires]
la macronie est prête à tout y compris à
un cynisme à toute épreuve ce n'est pas
nouveau les LR poursuivent l'opération
suicide ce n'est pas nouveau non plus on
peut batailler contre le RN on peut
attaquer charger affronter le RN mais
expliquer à longueur du discours que le
RNR raciste que le RN est fasciste que
le RNA anti républicain ne convain
personne à part quelques éditorialistes
de France Inter comment vous appelle
maintenant leur président
ce serait le premier président qu'on
appelle Jordan
des Marseillais d'ailleurs le trésorerie
du parti s'appelle Kevin donc
j'ai choisi un trésorerie qui s'appelle
Kevin Kevin se faire qui est député de
Moselle qui est le premier député qui a
appelé Kevin de l'Assemblée on est très
contentes populaires à l'Assemblée
nationale vous voulez vous inscrivez vos
Ch'tis à Miami alors
Jordan qui a une double casquette
président du RN et chauffeur de salle
mais visiblement sur le chauffage il a
suivi les recommandations
gouvernementales on était très bas en
température
qui revient désormais au rassemblement
national dans cette France dirigée par
Monsieur Macron
normalement c'est le moment où
[Applaudissements]
ça a fini par revenir on n'a pas le
droit de débattre en macronie mais je
pense que la seule chose qu'ils savent
dire c'est l'extrême droite il en fait
ils instrumentalisent l'extrême droite
ce qu'il pense l'extrême droite pour
entre guillemets rester au pouvoir c'est
incroyable je pense que je pense sinisme
de la Macchi
physiquement
c'est à dire elle physiquement parce que
on dit souvent que vous êtes le beau
gosse du parti aussi avec Julien Audoux
aussi est-ce que vous est-ce que c'est
votre style de femme ou pas
ça dépend on pourrait parler mais non
[Rires]
le 3
la base des accras
la morue
c'est bon
mention spéciale à David Racheline qui
est persuadé d'avoir encore des cheveux
et c'est beau d'y croire
[Applaudissements]
alors je t'explique ce qu'on fait j'ai
les cheveux
un balai brosse vraiment Alison elle a
des racines plus longs que mon parcours
scolaire donc c'était obligé que je
j'arrange quelque chose on compte 1 2 3
je suis super rapide
c'est vrai que ça fait plus net
et avec tous ces auteurs qui attendent
derrière leur stand on s'est dit que
c'était keV l'endroit idéal pour tester
les nouveaux filtres snapchat
[Musique]
Isabelle Adjani José d'ailleurs bonsoir
à toutes les deux on est très heureux de
vous recevoir
même si vous êtes un peu souffrante cher
Isabelle ce qui explique que vous êtes
masquée ce soir j'ai essayé de rester
avec les couleurs de Diane qui sont le
noir et le blanc mais voilà à cause d'un
petit soupçon de bronchiolite même si je
suis plus un bébé voilà je me retrouve
cortisonnée que des pour passer à
l'émission voilà voilà
j'ai l'impression que vous passez un bon
moment oui oui absolument
vous avez des crampes vous avez non j'ai
envie de dire
c'est vrai oui
chouchou et on lissera parvenir votre
courrier ah oui avec plaisir je suis
open voilà exactement
allez je bloque les paroles
la poutre dans l'oeil du
voisin je te dis ça démanger tout le
monde c'est une expression
ah il a entendu vagin c'est bien
très bien ah bah il est médecin pour lui
ça reste ce n'est pas ça c'est encore
plus d'animaux un autre record du monde
maintenant celui de Sailor le chien qui
récupère un frisbee le plus loin
possible l'engin était lancé par rode
son maître à 100 mètres
et c'est comme ça qu'on occupe la
mi-temps des matchs de foot au Canada
[Applaudissements]